y este domingo culminaron los juegos
olímpicos de invierno de beijing unas
justas que estuvieron marcada por una
serie de hechos extradeportivos como el
boicot diplomático y los casos de kobe
19 y en medio de ellos toda la polémica
que surgió en torno a la partida dora
camila valiera que en dio positivo por
dopaje previo a esta competencia pero
que se dio a conocer luego de deslumbrar
al mundo en la prueba por equipos para
analizar todo ello está con nosotros el
mar esa periodista en nuestra redacción
y especialista en deportes del ciclo
olímpico bienvenido a umar un placer
estar muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en este espacio
quisiéramos calificar estos juegos
deportivos y además evaluar un poquito
si es posible la actuación tanto del
comité olímpico internacional como el
comité organizador en medio de toda esta
situación que se presente esos son unos
juegos que dejaron tareas pendientes
por supuesto en lo deportivo destacar
ese récord de medallas con el que ganan
noruega nunca había ganado
con tantas medallas de oro como las 16
de noruega el récord anterior era de 14
pero lo extradeportivo y eso es lo que
no debería pasar quedan como muchas
cosas más y muchas tareas por analizar
una de ellas es el tema del patinaje
artístico ese estudio ese análisis que
queda pendiente de bajada de subir el
tope inferior de edad porque se ha
demostrado a la luz de lo sucedido acá
en en beijing que son muy vulnerables
ante abusos de cualquier tipo atletas
muy jóvenes como el caso de valiera como
el caso que comentábamos la semana
pasada de daria usach eba y pues todo lo
que vimos e incluso el ataque de nervios
que sufrió alexandra trozo va poco antes
de la ceremonia de premiación entonces
es una tarea que queda pendiente y una
tarea que queda pendiente ya que tú
mencionas la actuación del comité
olímpico internacional es evaluar la
efectividad de las sanciones que se han
impuesto sobre rusia son realmente
efectivas porque hasta lo que hemos
visto o lo que nos demostraron estos es
que siguen los mismos entrenadores los
mismos cuerpos técnicos las mismas
federaciones los dirigentes insertados
en las federaciones internacionales con
la misma influencia los mismos atletas
entonces en realidad cuesta distinguir
dónde está realmente la pena que se está
imponiendo sobre rusia por el dopaje de
estado